[Music]
some officers were just attacked so
brutally that it's really unimaginable
you know
ripping gas masks off officers faces
spraying their face with things like
wd-40
motor oil
pepper spray and then pushing the gas
mask back on their face and covering the
filter so that's basically suffocating
them
[Applause]
[Music]
the democrats had this election rigged
right from the beginning this is a fraud
tremendous voter fraud it's a corrupt
system the american people believe that
the election was not fair
that there was a lot of fraud and we're
not going to stop till it gets reversed
joe biden you will never be
my president i am trying to steal this
election in front of everyone and as i
told them 20 years ago i tell them again
i don't know how this is going to end
but if they want to fight they better
believe they've got work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so donald trump chose january 6 because
he knew the congress would be meeting in
the capitol it's pretty clear that what
they wanted was to stop the
certification of the election
democrats attempted the most brazen and
outrageous election
theft and there's never been anything
like this
and we're gonna have to fight much
harder we're gonna walk down and i'll be
there with you and we're gonna walk down
to the capitol
[Applause]
i believe that president trump invited
and incited the mob in plain view
because he held a rally by the white
house
when he
invited them to go to the capitol
you could see all these uh protesters
lining up outside these little fences so
there's probably a few hundred at that
point and a handful of cops dozens got
you know not not enough cops to
protesters
[Music]
the garden
moving past the police tearing down the
barriers police are moving
this is actually happening people
[Applause]
[Music]
the crowd was just
growing larger and larger
by the minute
i was
on the west front looking west
so i could just see the
hundreds thousands of people coming
towards the capitol from
from downtown dc
and
very quickly we just became
entirely overrun and
were so greatly outnumbered
that
it felt like the whole building became
surrounded
it was very frightening
we saw things starting to get out of
control then uh you know people climbing
the wall
um trying to get in uh fighting the
officers you know
over the trying to get over the barriers
and that sort of thing
i think they wanted to
commit acts of violence against members
of congress
because that's what they said
do you want your nose back
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
so i get up and i look and i see
now
it looks like protesters are coming
through
the police line
[Applause]
[Music]
most of the fights that you saw between
the
rioters
and the police were noticed mostly in
that kick it was almost like a
wrestling ring but that's on the west
side
on the east side is where these stairs
were
so i'm sitting there in my cab i noticed
two
trump supporters two riders jumped over
the fence they rocked back the fence to
the point where they actually ran over
the capitol
police department
it was
what felt like thousands of people
and very few officers
and it was sort of difficult to move
because the crowd was so large
this is
insanity
city man
it goes all the way down
where you get a bunch of people in the
crowd they're all packed tightly they're
all pushing forward they're all trying
to get over one another um you know
somebody falls and they're stepping on
your chest or you're crushed
um up against a wall or something long
designs you know very easily you know
you can have uh you can suffer traumatic
injury
i thought my entire squad was behind me
but it was only
three or four other officers so we
pushed forward to try to stop them but
we could only make it so far before
we were attacked and
that's when i was
struck in the face and knocked back and
then before i knew it i was attacked
from the right side too and i just was
on my back
and
my helmet had come down or someone was
on top of me
and i just couldn't see anything
and there i remember thinking
that i might not make it home alive
today
we
you know saw some of the sicker patients
right we saw the cardiac arrest we saw
some of the traumatic injuries the the
barriers that mpd were trying to keep
people back with the fences
they were actually using those to carry
patients out on
[Music]
there was one individual who
was tormenting and teasing us
saying
we're getting in that building
and i remember thinking no you're not
there's no way that you'll be able to
be that brazen and that aggressive to
actually make it past us
but
he was right unfortunately
stormed the capitol building they are
marching through now
[Applause]
speaker of the house nancy pelosi was in
the house chamber
so she's in one chamber and on the other
hand
vice president mike pence
was presiding over the senate vote those
two politicians were the most vulnerable
that day they were both singled out as
targets of the mob
[Music]
is not about the good people of arizona
and it will stand in recess until the
call of the chair
will boston protesters are in the
building thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
go
oh
what's the purpose of storming congress
itself because they work for us
they don't get to steal it from us
they don't get to tell us we didn't see
what we saw
it was a very close call on the senate
side because they
cleared the senate floor
moments before the mob broke in it could
have been much much worse on the senate
side they took over the floor
and the so-called shaman even
sat in mike pence's chair
so they violated the senate in a way
they didn't violate the house
[Music]
[Applause]
so some people have asked me you know
why didn't
why didn't we start shooting
you have 16 bullets in that gun there's
a thousand people
what are you going to do
how are you how are you going to stop
them because you imagine if there was a
swarm of bees all over you
um and they were very relentless um
constantly yelling racial epidemics and
wherever else it might be
going into some of these offices and
seeing how much destruction they cause
with just
ripping up filing cabinets throwing
papers all over throwing books off the
wall and just
destroying breaking windows breaking
whatever they could
the majority crowd was drunk that's
something that um a lot of news stations
did not speak on their day drinking and
a lot of them were drunk you smell the
alcohol under breath we want justice we
want
equal fair vote
we want a fair vote
we want a fair vote
nancy pelosi was spirited out of the
chamber
i did not see that because she was below
me
you can see
police have the gun tron uh members and
security have a huge bench and they're
throwing it up against the
the door of the chamber and you can hear
banging you can hear glass shattering
i was scared for my life i called my
family in california and it just gave me
this foreboding
fear that
we don't know what's happening here
this could be the end
the police are now telling us to get
down right behind our chairs because now
guns are drawn and they thought i assume
they thought they were going to start
[Music]
firing at any moment
they broke the glass
[Music]
and we heard this
crash into the speaker's lobby
which is right off the floor
and then we heard gunshots
[Applause]
capital police killed somebody they shot
through a closed door they killed a
woman
[Music]
then the politicians ran off left the
jackfruit thugs behind
the
police got us evacuated we were like
amongst the last people out on that
third floor
of the chamber
[Music]
[Applause]
today we come up here to the capitol
steps
tried to get in the capital they started
gassing us and masonis
we kept trying to hold the line and go
up to the state capitol we want to be
heard
that's all we want to do is be heard
nobody wants to listen they want to gas
and macy's
little people broke through and raced
through the building and then the
legislators got scared and left so we
didn't certify for joe biden so that's
good
i went basically from
that office in the senate area of the
capitol over to
the
the chute they call it the tunnel which
leads out to the inauguration stage
where some of the worst fighting
occurred
some officers were injured so we're just
attacked so brutally that it's really
unimaginable you know
ripping gas masks off officers faces and
spraying
spraying their face with things like
wd-40
motor oil
pepper spray and then pushing the gas
mask back on their face and covering the
filter so that's basically suffocating
them they had to breathe in what they
were sprayed with really anything they
had on them they were using against us
[Music]
they sprayed bear spray on the police
they were absolutely merciless they were
there
for blood
and you could hear it in their voices
this was a murderous mob
[Music]
i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath
and defend the constitution
and demand an end to this siege
we had an election
that was stolen from us it was a
landslide election and everyone knows it
especially the other side
but you have to go home now
we have to have
asked peace to go home
[Applause]
[Music]
i remember standing on the
inauguration stage on the
upper west terrace looking out and
seeing at that point the crowd had
diminished and thankfully our law
enforcement partners were there and were
continuing to push them back i think at
that point the national guard arrived
just
painfully too late
the president invited me
and he invited me i had to come it's uh
i i couldn't not come
it's too important
it's too important not to come i feel
like i was supposed to be here so when
you're charged inside because
well because i believe god wanted me to
be here so i am here and
she came along to support mom
[Music]
hours passed without us looking at our
watches
and then we were told the building was
clear this is many hours later after the
national guard and the metropolitan
police came to the aid and the rescue of
the capitol please
[Music]
they resumed the count back up so we
went back to
almost business as normal except
shooting down the house chamber you see
like the broken glass and the broken
chamber door
that was kind of unusual and uh
people continued to object to the
account
and it took longer than i should and i
probably finally
finally got out of there about 3 30 in
the morning
it was trashed you know what i mean
there was garbage everywhere you know
what i mean it wasn't like um
if you've ever been in the capitol prior
to it taking place the capital is very
much like a sanctuary right very much
like a church
it's clean it's very pristine
the aftermath of it you know just kind
of showed
you know what happened
[Music]
i remember
finding out that he had died and
just
how it was
such a punch in the gut to
all of us
[Music]
to have politicians
downplay and diminish the events of that
day
when so many of us literally shed blood
to protect them
is incredibly frustrating and
infuriating you don't go through that
day
whether it was verbal about violence or
physical violence or psychological
violence you don't that that stays with
you for a very long time i hope that
people realize how
bad it was
and how
much worse it could have been
but that
our
democracy
is fragile
as evidenced by that day
uh
[Music]
tower two collapsed onto the marriott
hotel
and the marriott hotel collapsed around
us pitch black you couldn't breathe the
dust was so thick it was caked in my
ears and in my mouth
and i was trying to breathe
and i was on my hands and knees and i
was crawling